- [Mark] All right, Scotty.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Welcome back.
(both laugh)
- It's good to be back.
- [Mark] So let's just
start over from the top.
- All right.
- [Mark] You're from where?
- [Scotty] I'm from Montana, originally.
- [Mark] Montana?
- [Scotty] Yeah.
- [Mark] Okay, and you've
been in LA how long?
- [Scotty] I've been in LA
about 15 years, off and on.
- [Mark] 15 years?
- Yeah.
First time was 10
and I went back to Seattle
for awhile, and came back.
- [Mark] Okay and then...
So currently you're not dealing anymore,
you're rolling for the-
- Yeah, I work for all the
drug dealers right now.
I used to sell, but
there's too many problems.
You gotta collect, and beat people up,
you get in fights and,
it's just too much hassle-
- [Mark] Tell me about the fight
that got you in trouble.
- Well, a guy, he came to
my area and he was just,
after he eat, he'd just throw
his food down and make a mess.
And I thought it was
one of my girlfriends,
so I'm picking up this
dude's stuff after him.
And I see him eating, and he takes it,
throws his plate down, I'm
like, "Dude, pick that shit up
and throw it in the garbage," you know.
"Just 'cause we're homeless,
doesn't mean we have to be slobs."
He's like, "Fuck you".
I said, "What, fuck me?
Dude, pick your shit up
and throw it in the garbage
or I'm gonna knock you the fuck out".
He's like, "Whatever."
He starts laying down his blanket.
I'm like, "What are you doing now?"
And he's like, "I'm going to sleep".
"Right in front of my tent?"
He's like, "Yeah."
Man, I was gonna let him sleep there,
I was gonna walk by and kick him
every time I walked to
my tent and stomp on him.
I had enough of that dude.
I told him, "If anybody says
anything about me in this area,
I'm gonna hit you in the mouth, dude."
He's like, "Go for it."
He swung at me, dude, I hit
him twice, dude, killed him.
Broke his neck, snapped his brainstem,
he died instantly on Crocker.
- [Mark] No.
There's a backstory
here, which is the fact
that you're a Golden Gloves champion.
- Yeah, three times Golden Gloves Boxers
and I'm also Special Forces.
So the police automatically assumed
that I knew hitting him in
the mouth would kill him-
- [Mark] You were in
Special Forces, which-
- With the army, yeah-
- [Mark] With the army,
so you know how to fight?
- I know how to-
- [Mark] Between Golden Gloves and that.
- Yeah I know how to
really, really fight, yeah.
I don't even like to fight,
but I know how to fight, yeah.
I don't like it.
- [Mark] If you get
into a jam you have to.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And you can
take care of yourself.
- Usually they go like five,
six people, with baseball bats,
canes and stuff after
me because they know me.
They don't come with their hands.
They come with knives, baseball bats.
Yeah, six, 10 people tell me,
you can't sell any more drugs,
'cause I'm taking all their money.
- [Mark] The story you told me yesterday,
tell me when you had to move
from one street to another, what happened?
- Well what happened was
that JT used to sell spice,
I used to buy from him,
but he'd mix it with weed,
and I burned a UA with the
vets that made me homeless.
So I got pissed off.
I told him, "Dude, I'm not
buying your crap anymore."
He said, "Well, there's
nothing you can do about it."
I said, "Really?
I went to the store and
started buying spice.
Then I hired nine people,
started putting people in different areas,
I started choking on his supply.
Pretty soon I would sell all the spice
and he couldn't sell one stick.
Pretty soon I started
getting everybody mad.
So, finally 10 of them
came with baseball bats
and everything and they told me,
"We're not telling you
you can't sell anymore-"
- [Mark] 10 guys with baseball bats?
- Yeah, they're tell me,
"You can't sell on Crocker
to move to town, otherwise," you know.
I asked him, "Why'd you
bring the baseball bat?"
They're like, "'Cause we know you."
I'm like, "Oh man."
I moved into town, so-
- [Mark] They didn't
wanna see you no more.
- Yeah, but I choked them out,
in military camp, began to choke them off.
I was selling 600 joints a day.
I completely ended their...
If I wanted to,
I could have completely
put them out of business,
but I let them go, I let them slide,
'cause I started getting
into too many fights,
too many collections and too-
- [Mark] And then that
fight where the guy died,
you ended up--
- Yeah, I had a murder charge,
15 years to life over my head.
- [Mark] And the safety was the videotape.
- Yeah, it was on video, thank God.
If it wasn't a video that
the guy threw a punch,
I would have been 15 to life in prison,
regardless if the guy started the fight,
the guy made a mess,
the guy threw a punch.
It didn't matter, I killed
him, made me the bad guy.
I don't understand-
- [Mark] So you didn't do jail time?
- I did, I did 200 days
at County, 208 days,
I did a year at a drug and rehab program,
and on three years probation,
I got $11,000 in fines and
restitution that I paid
for two punches, I had to
buy the bitch funeral...
fucking flowers for his fucking funeral.
I paid $7,400 for flowers
for this faggot ass.
Motherfucker, I couldn't
even pay for funeral
for my wife when she died
'cause the County took all my shit.
I couldn't have her cremated.
- [Mark] And you're no
longer able to deal anymore
or sell because-
- I can, but I don't wanna
'cause it's too much-
- [Mark] Well, because if you get-
- If I get in any trouble I have to-
- [Mark] If you have to
collect from somebody
and get physical-
- Yeah, I'll get in big trouble.
For murder this time, real.
- [Mark] So your wife passed away?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Tell me about that.
- Well, see, everything was going good.
I was just about to buy a house in PV,
I had one in Torrance.
I just sold my house at Carson.
Had two businesses, married,
everything was going good.
- [Mark] And PV, which is Palos Verdes,
is a very expensive neighborhood.
- Eight million dollars for my house.
Come on.
You say PV if you're from Palos Verdes,
if you say Palos Verdes, they're like,
"Get out of here of here faggot.
You're not from here," you know.
You better say PV if you're there.
That's how you know
that you're from there.
That's when you have money, you know
- [Mark] And that was all from selling?
- I sold a...
I didn't sell drugs at first.
I had my own two companies.
I had computer company, Scott's PC,
I had So-Cal Tools, I sold tools online.
I had two businesses, two
successful businesses.
I owned my own house, everything.
They took everything.
They took $500,000 in
child support away from me.
$500,000.
This is 400,000 Euro.
They ain't give me back any money.
Just took my money and said,
"Thanks for helping out a kid."
That was it.
She took all her stuff off Facebook,
all of our conversations and stuff.
She said if you're not my
father, I don't want to know.
I really liked her too,
I really wished she was my
daughter, but she wasn't, so...
I didn't have a wife
and I didn't have a daughter
either at that point.
That was okay, it kept me really alive,
the whole time it was, "Maybe
this is my daughter, man."
I'd go across the Gulf
of Alaska on a boat,
I could swim faster
than the motherfucker...
(Scotty stammering)
Sailing into the fucking
abyss and I just...
I wanted to jump, I
wanted to jump overboard.
And I'm such a good swimmer, man,
I was going to jump off the tail end
and go right into the big fat
dude, just get shredded, man.
And I was about ready to jump
and a dolphin jumped up,
almost hit me in the face,
on the third tier there, dude.
And I'm like, "What the f..?"
Freaked me out.
I saw outside of this boat was the moon,
on the other side of the sun.
And I just about jumped in.
And I knew if I went into the propeller,
that's was the only way I would die.
- [Mark] And you wanted
to do this because...
- I'd lost my wife, lost everything, dude,
I didn't care anymore.
If I had known if she
was my daughter or not,
I would have jumped.
I didn't do that.
I'd have done it, I admit it.
But I had to see if this is
my daughter or not, so...
That was first.
And when I found out
it wasn't my daughters,
that sucked, so...
- [Mark] So you lost all your money-
- My wife, lost my wife.
Couldn't give a fuck about my money.
I give a fuck about my wife.
- [Mark] (indistinct)
to help the situation.
You've had some rough (indistinct).
- I didn't give a shit
about all the money I had.
I had really nice stuff,
really nice house,
really nice cars, everything.
I didn't give a fuck about that.
I miss my wife.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- That's 10 years ago and I still feel it.
Put me homeless, put
me if I got unemployed,
put me homeless-
- [Mark] That's probably why you're here.
- Yeah, and I can't move forward.
I can't.
I have photographic memory.
I cannot get out of my mind.
People are like, "Oh time will ki..."
No, time doesn't fucking matter.
I loved her to death, dude.
It doesn't matter.
There's not enough time ever.
I'll never, ever not love her, you know,
I'll never not hurt.
10 years?
Fuck, it feels just like
it happened yesterday.
Fuck, leave it up to time.
Bullshit. Bullshit.
Especially with a photographic memory.
Oh, fuck me!
I remember the smells.
I remember the clothes she was wearing.
I remember everything before
she died. (exhales deeply)
It's really bad.
- [Mark] And you carry that with you
everywhere you go, every day-
- Yeah, I burned down everything I owned,
so I couldn't even see her.
When my first wife died,
I got a burn permit,
burned down my house,
everything she owned,
everything I owned, dude.
Grabbed some clothes,
got in my car and drove
from Montana to Phoenix, Arizona.
That's where I moved first.
Yeah.
- [Mark] Show me your bite wounds.
- (chuckles) A guy tried to
bite my finger off in a fight.
That one they had 17
doctors working on me.
- [Mark] This is from
somebody here on the street?
- Yeah, it was a guy, one of
my ex-girlfriend's boyfriend,
She brought money from me
and he said she wasn't gonna pay me.
I said, "You were smocking
my shit too, motherfucker."
Dude, hit him too, dude.
And I went to choke him,
but my hand caught on fire,
and this half is melted
(indistinct) on fire.
So I tried to lock him up, but I couldn't.
And I let go and he bit my
finger and tried to bite it off.
- [Mark] And then you've
got another bite wound?
- Yeah, then there came an
enforcer, I was beating him up,
he tried to bite my shoulder
off in another fight.
He bit me right there.
- [Mark] Here, pull it back.
That's a bite wound?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Oh gee.
- Yeah, bite my whole
shoulder off right there.
That's a bite right there too,
and that's a bite right there.
But my toxic the levels were like 22.6.
They're like, "You're dead."
23 it's comatose.
And I said, the doctor was
like, "Man, you got 21%-"
- [Mark] So these are
infections from the bites?
- Yeah, so the human mouth is so dirty,
if anybody bites you, you
better go get yourself fixed,
'cause you're going to die.
That's the worst mouth on the planet
except for a Komodo dragon.
Dude, I'd rather get bit by
a rat or a dog than a person.
Hell yeah.
- [Mark] And this happened
here at (indistinct)
- Yeah, yeah.
I think that guys chewing on a sewer pipe,
'cause I got so many garbage
in my shit, that I almost died.
I had 17 people working on me, two teams,
a red team, blue team, they
were like, (exhales deeply)
I couldn't even breathe on myself,
while they were packing
me from the inside out,
I breathe on myself and I would die.
That's how bad it was.
Yeah, it was fun.
Beekeeper suit, all that. (all chuckle)
- [Mark] You were telling me
about the drugs you selling, man.
Are you selling sticks-
- [Scotty] I sell like...
I sell everything,
but I tried to keep it with just spice
'cause that's just an infraction.
- [Mark] And spice is a new drug?
- [Scotty] Yeah, it's a
gateway drug between all them.
Crystal, heroin, crack,
it's a good gateway drug.
So that was a really
good if you sell that,
you can make a ton of money.
I made a thousand dollars a night,
every night, no problem.
I was going to take over the Cuban corner.
I had made three grand, but I
had to beat some Cubans, so-
- [Mark] And spice is as
addictive, more addictive?
- [Scotty] More addictive
than any other drugs
on the planet, just
about, 'cause it's strong.
It's strong as hell.
It'll nod you, just like heroin.
It comes down to between crystal.
It'll bring it down to
normal, you know what I mean?
It will bring you up from crack, it's...
It's a gateway drug, it's
perfect for everything.
Even marijuana, you
get high with it, it's-
- [Mark] So marijuana...
Let's get off the drugs.
Tell me about your wife.
- [Scotty] So I was married
for 10 years to her,
and I found out she was
really sick and I told her
to go to the hospital and
find out what's wrong.
You know, she couldn't eat
couldn't swallow, she...
And they gave her some
albuterol sulfate and stuff
and said she had emphysema from smoking
and she kept getting worse.
I took her to another doc...
Her friend took her to another doctor.
I told her, "Bring there
albuterol sulfate," you know.
"Tell them you've already been here.
This ain't working.
Go to step B."
She came back with the same shit.
I said, "Fuck, these doctors."
I went into the hospital
myself to USC general.
I told the intake nurse,
"You better sit down and
listen to me right now.
My wife can't eat.
She, this is day two,
day three, she's dead.
Run every test you can, dude.
Find out what the fuck is
going on with her," you know.
"If I don't like what you're doing,
I'll go to another hospital, get it done.
They found out she had terminal cancer,
that she was going to die.
The intake nurse was like,
"Man, I remember you."
He said, "Man, you said
check everything, dude.
Your words were strong."
He said, "We did."
He said: "Your wife is got terminal cancer
and it's negative.
And I said, "Well, that's good."
He said, "No, that's bad."
I said, "What do you mean?
Negative is good, isn't it?"
And he said, "Negative,
it means there's no cure.
She's dead.
There's nothing they can do.
Positive means chemotherapy, drugs,
something work to put in remission.
Hers was negative which means she's dead.
There's nothing we can do."
- [Mark] How long did she live after that?
- Three months
Just like the nurse told me.
The doctor lied to me said
she should live for years.
They all liars, they just want your money.
I put her in the Cancer
Institute of Phoenix,
$300,000, a hundred
thousand dollars a month,
she called me a couple months
later, "I want to go home."
She said, "I hate it here."
"$700,000 a month and you hate it.
Are you serious?
What the fuck, man!"
She said, "Man, people are here dying.
They got money, and people are
just waiting for them to die,
so they take their money.
Nobody visit them, this is so depressing."
I said, "Come home, baby."
And she died a week later.
She had a heart attack.
She had holes in her esophagus.
I paid for the endoscopy.
The Kaiser Permanente wouldn't approve it.
I had to pay $15,000 out
of my own pocket for it.
They ran the endoscopy down, the tube,
and the camera down her
throat, saw her holes.
Her heart and lungs
were fill up with water,
'cause she had holes in her esophagus.
So every couple weeks
she had to go get drained
to take the pressure off.
She was going in and she
had a heart attack and died.
(exhales deeply)
I knew it too.
I knew it.
There was nothing I
could do about it, so...
- [Mark] And then you were
married a second time, right?
- Yeah, my first wife
passed away a long time ago.
- [Mark] Oh, that was before?
- Yeah, before her, she...
I wasn't ever going to get married again.
I wasn't ever going to even
date anybody ever again.
My wife, I was married, she had a baby-
- [Mark] This was back in Montana?
- She's six weeks old and
both died in a car crash.
- [Mark] You and your six weeks old baby?
- My wife and her baby
both died in a car crash.
She was taking my baby
to her mom's to babysit.
We were working at Hamilton, had a...
I was a little law and she had to drive.
I had six DUIs so she
said, "You can't drive."
I told her she's really tired,
I want to drive, you know?
She's like, "No, I'll just...
I'll meet you at work.
- [Mark] You had 6 DUIs.
- Yeah, six total, yeah, I had six.
I had one in Germany, I have three in...
two in Montana, two in Arizona.
I got one in Germany and
one in someplace else.
I can't remember.
Everywhere...
One in Germany, that was a big one.
That's six total.
So she's like, "You can't drive."
So I was like, "Okay."
So when you're going there,
there's this 40 miles of
straight and there's one curve
before you get into town at Hamilton,
and there's a mountain and
everybody hits the mountain.
So she died almost instantly they said.
- [Mark] Did she fall asleep?
- Yeah.
She missed the curve, hit the mountain,
just like almost everybody.
I was at work, I couldn't
figure out where she was.
I couldn't find her, she
didn't show up to work.
My boss told me that your
wife she is at the hospital
and I said, "What?"
He said...
He didn't want to tell me,
because he knew I ruined my production
and I hit him in the mouth,
I threw him through an aquarium.
He had a salt water aquarium and windows.
Yeah, I hit him in the mouth,
threw him into sales board, dude,
just started beating his ass, dude.
People grabbed me, pull me off.
Dude, I was going to kill him, dude.
- [Mark] Because he let you work all day?
- Yeah, he let me work and
my wife died in the hospital
while I was at work, motherfucker would.
I did over $80,000 worth
of damage to his aquarium
and his mirrors that you can
see out, but couldn't see into,
I threw him right through everything, man.
I just started pounding him, dude
My friend, Jim Allen saved his life, dude.
Grabbed me.
He's like 270.
Barely can pull me up, dude.
I was going to kill him, dude.
I got to the hospital, dude.
They were both dead by
the time I got there,
I was so frustrated.
I lost my job too 'cause...
Can't hit your boss, I guess.
(indistinct crosstalk)
They didn't like it, so...
He was too scared to fire me too.
He didn't want to fire me, he was like...
He almost let me keep my job
'cause he didn't want me
to beat his ass again.
(Scotty chuckles)
- [Mark] Well, your
behavior is understandable.
- Yeah, I was pissed, dude.
- [Mark] (indistinct) let up.
- Yeah, but it's all gonna change.
It's all gonna change,
you know what I mean?
It's a reason for everything.
I mean, I must've done
a bunch of bad stuff
to get involved in the
stuff I got, you know.
I hope it's done.
Hopefully, I paid it off, you know.
- [Mark] You're still using?
- Yeah, I still use, yeah.
I use just spice and crystal.
I do crystals, some heroin.
Some, every now and they'll do
some crack, and some cocaine,
but I don't do weed or a
beer anymore, alcohol...
I'm Indian, so I'm alcoholic
and I'm a Norwegian Viking,
so I get drunk, dude, I'd go to jail-
- [Mark] Are you an American Indian-
- I'm Native American and a
Viking, I'm an Indian Viking,
so I get drunk, I go to jail.
I go to jail right away.
It's all automatic, you know,
I'm a berserker drunk, you know,
so we can't control ourselves, you know?
And I'm Norwegian, we go nuts.
I scare everybody, the
whole police department.
They locked me in my own
special room, dude, they...
Everybody knows me.
- [Mark] And then you can throw
a punch too on top of that-
- Yeah, yeah. (Scotty chuckles)
So they all know me.
They're like, "Oh God."
They'll put me, if somebody else's there,
they will actually lock me up
and put me in a separate isolation room
and lock to the bench
to keep other people protected from me.
That's how dangerous they think I'm.
I'm not that dangerous.
- [Mark] And you've been
in prison a few times.
- Yeah, a couple of times.
For that murder charges
that I ran over a cop,
punch him up, broke him,
ran him over with my car.
He was talking shit, so I
popped him in the mouth.
He was saying my word wasn't worth shit.
I said, "Well, I'll tell you what.
I'm going to give you my
word I'm going to drop you."
He said, "What?"
Wham! I broke his fucking
jaw, knocked him out, bitch.
Yeah, fucking knocked him
out and I went to back up,
this guy wants to get in my car.
He was already handcuffed.
I said, "Get in the fucking
car," and he's like, "Wha..."
"Get in the fucking car."
I went to close the door,
I shut it on his leg,
I backed out and he fell out
into the fucking gas station parking lot.
So I slammed on the
brakes and that cop got up
and tried to stop my car,
so I slammed on the brake,
'cause it was going to rip his arms off.
I ran him over and shattered
his hip, broke his legs,
19 places shattered his hip.
I already broke his jaw,
broke his walkie talkie-
- [Mark] So the guy that you
killed, you also drove over?
- No, that was a cop.
That was a different cop.
That was another guy. (chuckles)
- [Mark] (chuckles) Oh, I'm losing track-
- Yeah, that's a cop that
I got in a fight with-
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
- That was a police...
I got 60 assaults and 4
are on police officers.
So that was one of my police
officers assault stories
that I was in...
I was pretty mad. (Scotty chuckles)
So they say I was going to be buried,
but I hired Earnest Lutz.
He's at $6,000 an hour lawyer.
So he goes to the district attorney,
has the judge on my case.
So I got a $30,000 in
fines and restitution,
three years probation,
720 hours of CalTrans.
I pick it up the freeway
for a whole fucking
summer for three years-
- [Mark] But beats being in jail.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Three years I had CalTrans.
720 hours, they didn't think
I was going to make it.
- [Mark] So what that is, for
people don't understand is-
- Community services-
- [Mark] You're cleaning up
debris on the side of the road
instead of being in prison
- Yup. Or community service.
And CalTrans is the worst one.
It's worse than community service
- [Mark] And this was
for running over the cop?
- Punching him in the
mouth and running him over.
- [Mark] Punch him?
- Yeah, I punch him in the mou...
He said my word wasn't worth a shit.
I said: "I'm going to give you my work,
I'm going to drop you."
He said, what?
I put him into sleep. (Scotty chuckles)
I said, "Your job is to protect and serve,
not harass and annoy, motherfucker, dude.
You're pissing me the fuck off."
"What?" (Scotty giggles)
Bitch.
I don't like anybody.
Like even the cops know me.
They told me I got to get rid
of all the bunk (indistinct),
I grabbed this big...
I don't know what it was, big crate thing,
dresser type thing.
I was going to throw it right
through this cop cars cruiser.
I said, "You said, put it on the thing.
Move your fucking cruiser, dude."
And he's like, "Oh, please
don't throw it through my car."
He said, "I don't want to
do the paperwork on it."
I said, "Well."
He said," I know you're
going to do it too."
He said, "I'll move my
car." (Scotty chuckles)
I said... (Scotty grunts)
But I had the whole thing up, dude,
I was going to slam it through his car.
Everybody knows me there.
Even the cops don't mess with me anymore,
they're like, (Scotty puffs air)
"He's nuts, just move your car,
move your car out of his
way." (Scotty laughs)
(Mark muffled by laughter)
But it took me about seven years
to get that kind of reputation.
At first, I couldn't sell
anything anywhere to anyone.
You got to earn respect
and then you can do it.
Now, I can sell anything
I want anywhere I want.
I just don't feel like it right now.
- [Mark] And then if you
wanted to quit and get clean
and start your life over,
you think you could do it?
- I could do that 15 years ago.
I could have, I just don't want to.
There's nothing for me to do anymore.
I've done everything, you know.
I've been rich, I've been married.
I've been...
Owned businesses, I've done everything.
Been everywhere.
Seen everything, almost.
- [Mark] Yeah, but this is a dead end
that's going to take you down eventually.
- Doesn't matter. Don't matter.
If I die, that's perfect.
That's rest, finally get a
from all this shit, you know?
I'm not going to the heaven
and kissing God's ass for fucking eternity
that's not what I want.
Fuck that, I'm not going to do it.
I want to die when I die.
- [Mark] You (indistinct).
- [Scotty] Yeah, I want to die when I die.
I want to be dead.
That's it.
I don't want to kiss God's ass
for eternity in bastard heaven.
Fuck all that.
I want to die
Period.